welcome to podcast Ville the Church of
what's happened now is proud to welcome
to the show then Sarah watches let me
tell you something you tired of choosing
between luxury styling high-end quality
and an affordable price tag then several
watches wants to help with timepieces
that expertly blend style timing and a
class with a price tag you'll never
expect on a watch built this well each
collection is bold modern and guaranteed
to elevate your game so money little
buddies over at the fine starbucks comes
up to you when one of the little apple
watches and you'll be like BAM that's
nice but look at this Vince arrow I'm
dropping on you listen to me this thing
I get watches said to me all the time
there's the first time I'm I'm finally
becoming a professional comic I thought
it was time to get a watch and I watch
rocky do when I'm in mourning to hold
the girl in if you wanna have a good
time you gotta have a good watch and
that's why I'm coming to you one of the
best watches out there then several
watches don't do me a favor right don't
just get a watch this is gonna hell of
eight your game and just get a Vince
arrow watch go check out this arrow I
get the watch dotnet right now today
even better the Saros giving all the
family to church listeners 15% off their
entire purchase with promo code Church
at checkout it's time to step up your
watch game even uncle Joey did go check
out Vince arrow I get the watch dotnet
right now you're not gonna be sorry and
also to my family over at on it always
supplying the best supplements in the
house as a matter of fact today I want a
little hike and I'd there now for brain
I walked for an hour I was sweating like
an animal I went all my points last
night I got a high and no later than I
had to make it up I go to kickboxing
tomorrow you get to tears I'm gonna jump
up and down anyway go Telecom right now
press in shirt and get 10% of your
entire order whether it's alpha brain
shroom tech head force protein milk
listen to me they're not playing games
gonna calm right now Lee kick that
mother
[ __ ] mules the Churchill what's
happening now you bad [ __ ]
greetings
Jorge Perez here what's ayats' here
what's up Papa well some are bling you
know man
just wanted to [ __ ] see you so I got
a lad it's tough I'm down there you know
you know I got a fucked-up be it so I
try to go to the store cuz I get sick on
a little Canyon
so I puked and I get down there oh yeah
I gotta go to the store smellin like
some [ __ ] bump you're right it's got
an embarrassing Calvin I only go down
there once a week twice a week you know
besides that I just stick around on the
P are you doing you look good god bless
you still here 25 yeah door banging it
out it's the [ __ ] prison tried to
stop you before like Tupac don't get out
on bail fresh out of jail California
[ __ ] one of the fools that I fought
in there to just hit me up on he hit me
up on Instagram he's a homie you know me
as this and I had a little
miscommunication it's like I'm not
tripping and just glad you're doing good
and I was like [ __ ] is this a setup
wanted to meet up and [ __ ] good people
change yeah no it was cookie did change
people change
yeah you can't you can't that's why I
hate these accusations look at chachi
now she's gonna tell me this happened 20
years ago is that what this same forum
happy days and then he has no well for a
while you can't people change
don't pedophile maybe they won't wind up
maybe they couldn't cope the night
before you don't know that [ __ ]
situation you don't know this situation
and happen these people don't ever want
to come clean so then you're [ __ ] just
saying listen I did 22 eight-balls night
night before and I was still owned up
that then you showed up with that little
bikini top you drove me [ __ ] crazy
and I figured I'd tell you and I want to
squeeze money it takes it's different
you know when I was doing drugs at the
creepy [ __ ] we all do dogs yeah I mean
I've done so kind of creepy [ __ ] but I
mean like I kind of feel me and you have
this sensor or you're like like when I
take the dress off and she hasn't said a
word like in 90 seconds on my a or you
cool or like am i scaring you know
they know what time it is you don't go
back to an apartment what I do with an
Eightball now you're walking right even
if you're married you know yeah show me
your [ __ ] you have to do something I
mean that's just three level type [ __ ]
you come over you do an Eightball
don't hit me with some story at 6:00 in
the morning you gotta go you did that
snore
now you gotta show me some yeah let me
sniff your bra something is that type of
body and that's the truth that's how
that's guys mentality and oh yeah that's
the way guys mentalities always been you
know it's just something it's just I
used to bring girls to the crib and have
coke speed [ __ ] PCP every weed and be
like what's up do you want to hang out
or do you want to go home and you tell
them the truth
listen if we do this I'm just gonna get
a look at ya I'm already [ __ ] up I'm
up here I got nowhere to go I live six
miles away
cab fare I'm gonna have to do something
cook suck something to get home anyway
put the lamp up [ __ ] horrible
horrible what's gonna happen now
everybody's only gonna finger point that
about something they did thirty [ __ ]
years ago
you know we're talking about the other
day with our lady about you know they're
tripping on Ali no no we were talking
about when she Jones went off oh yeah
those businesses [ __ ] did you hear he
said he saw a bunch of crazy [ __ ] you
know boy it's everybody wants attention
we live in that light dawg that's what
these people do they seek attention so
they got how do each other I didn't get
[ __ ] in the ass he laid me once he
raped me three times really he came over
three times to rape you're not I come
out with this you know every day is
always [ __ ] something this is Los
Angeles
these people are broken were broken as
performers some yeah along the line we
saw somebody getting stabbed something
[ __ ] happen [ __ ] yeah and it stays
with you for a long [ __ ] time what do
you think happens then you give these
idiots this few you give them you give
these young people a fire what do you
think they do and you girls and you guys
or whether
don't [ __ ] help any oh you know with
your [ __ ] [ __ ] love affair you
know these people and you're going down
there with a poster what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you
[ __ ] people this guy's a [ __ ] Nami
Grammer on the outside but in today's
world we don't even care you know we
don't even care it doesn't really matter
some man we're talking about last last
night like Paul Mooney sucked richard
briers dick it's on one of the wild
something like that does that make me
hate oh ma you know he's one of my
mentors
what am i I'm saying like what we choose
to pick and decide what's right and
what's wrong in our world yeah some
people like to go darker and they were
just like [ __ ] it you know I always make
the point about the Sopranos
the most interesting thing about The
Sopranos is what that whenever you want
to surprise your wife watched her with
you or your girlfriend it was that good
of a show yeah but he cheated on his
wife once every two episodes way twice
an episode yeah yeah I watched it they
understood that they don't know what he
was this shit's been going on for
[ __ ] years but you know what if you
fell into something 20 years ago before
you open your mouth contact that person
yeah hey hey years ago you said so much
did some so I just didn't dig and and
and you know you're changing me and made
me gen again you go listen I'm sorry you
know what can I do apologize or
something like that if you want to go to
the press go to the press I went to
prison for kidnapping you don't see him
cry I put him in the trunk of a [ __ ]
car you don't see him don't give me
ideas no he's a great guy he's coming on
the show like in November's coming I'm
three weeks of some we talk man you got
your kidnap victim coming but I talked
to that dude I have to yeah for my own
peace of mind I'm little dude about
giving Bobby Lenten the money I owe him
and seven I just sent him a check on
Monday in the mail what'd you do the
Bobby I borrow four hundred didn't pay
him back 20 [ __ ] years ago first and
then you know once I can coat that that
went wrong I'm all those guys bro that
you know I [ __ ] up yeah I [ __ ] up I
hold before - I [ __ ] up and now if it
was a I'm explaining to you I owe it to
housing people $20,000 for coke again I
gotta see it ready to die
helps people see a red dime they play
the game mainly what they would get
themselves it straight up
that's the debt you think people here
old me money people be money I forgot
cuz I knew I know the game I was it
mm-hmm
you got caught with your guard down yeah
that's what life is about sometimes you
win sometimes you lose at the end as
long as you break even you're happy you
know I seen someone that owe me money
man and I remember it was a QP remember
stress weed a quarter panels 125 bucks
no yeah well stress sweet is that ugly
we that Metzger brought over in the
tires and [ __ ] nice to sell that [ __ ]
and I fronted it to some guy that was
from my neighborhood and then he ends up
getting caught with it but I found out
he didn't it was just a story his family
moved them back to his to his old city
and all the sites you have any idea like
if I sat here with you and we just sat
him I can probably do a 20-hour podcast
of all the people I'd beat for cocaine
oh man I beat up or like nothing
mentally I know Jimmy likes Blake ayo me
I got you be like I'll be back on now
[Laughter]
like what I mean you look on the front
of the a boy I know you're ten years
yeah I'll be back here in the morning
just gotta cash this check it's at my
grandmother's house [ __ ] I'm [ __ ]
grandmother you you you you catch people
at their week later and it's an
addiction thing that's not does not mean
you're a bad person so much a drug thing
no yeah people [ __ ] how many kids me
mommy
you know you get horrible sad about
crack four ladies will crack first hit
people selling the kids far it was
[ __ ] crazy when crack hit bro I
remember going to a neighborhood that
was a weed neighborhood and going back
in 84 85 a crack came and seeing piles
and not knowing I was so like I knew a
coke cause I grew up around [ __ ] coke
yeah but seeing those little vials and
Goliath miles on every street corner in
puddles um New York and going pro that
weed they were like this
we don't lose one hey nobody's sleeping
over here bye-bye 88-89 you were just
hearing some horrific stories about
cocaine I lived it I said I was up 60
grand and next thing you know I was down
150,000 and my phone didn't stop ringing
Jack right now Jesus Christ my left
Aspen my debts were insane yeah well my
friend Aspen was less I'm you an ass but
I go right after I got separated I took
my car and in 91 October 91 maybe
November of 91 I got in a car and I said
[ __ ] it let me go up to Aspen and just
get my head together and breves living
in Boulder had a little acura integra
so he lives in Colorado Boulder at the
time I was doing in Boulder and I had
left pretty much I left Aspen the middle
of night George
danby for the night yeah cops watching
me I owed don't let ty out everybody I
was doing that scam where you know but I
made you out of money too see that's
what people understand having a week
they all made money secured all I was
doing was I was getting announced for
800 but it in Colorado in those days the
answers was $1,800 oh [ __ ]
that's $1,000 to play with reckon on it
and [ __ ] yeah cut oh yeah and cut all I
did was take a plane and pick it up and
bring it back and I was getting like he
the guy wouldn't even really way they'd
give me an allowance is 12 ounces for
$9,500 borrowing them guns and I take
the coke and whack it with two ounces
and bro by the time I got off the plane
if I have 14 ounces.this nine of them
were already sold so if I told you give
me fifteen hundred back to 2250 at a
nine o'clock by nine o'clock
you had your [ __ ] but guess what I knew
you were a fiend
so I scabby the 2200 and then you give
me back seven four [ __ ] cut AME
exactly to the game so I get you in the
end so I kept doing this to people and I
was making
George and I'm George I can't imagine I
was making money to the point where I
was like I was getting I was snorting 12
grams a night abalone shove the good
[ __ ] and still counting cash in the
morning going Jesus clam because if I
took that coke and cut it into grams and
sold it there have been ridiculous
ridiculous I would put bro up my coke
with what I was doing - it was way
better than anybody the other side and I
left a rock in there God he gave me 50 I
always left 2.5 rock the rest was shake
that was flake and the cut was sprinkled
in there and you didn't know the
difference because once you cracked that
rock and they were overpowered I still
kept a try with ghosts I would throw 9
on 28 9 on 28th is what that's nothing
that's wilder and now you get 3700 for a
toll on investment I got bro I can sell
37 grams in two [ __ ] hours an asset
in those days and I had two dudes
working from a car into it over there
like was it that it was in 1984 was the
cocaine capital the United States of
America huh you know it's funny I'm
gonna end this I'm gonna end this
podcast with Smuggler's blues and I was
telling my wife because I heard it today
and I've told my wife that I remember
when he mentioned Telluride I was living
in basalt Colorado but every weekend the
guys I lived with took a ride somewhere
like to go pick up or to know they would
just they work construction one was a
girl I got you it was horrible we all
grew up together they were just three or
four years older than I was and I lived
in the basement I paid rent and I
dreamed Friday they got home from work
we would pick up coolers and we would go
somewhere so one weekend we went to
Boulder one weekend we went to rifle and
one we going to tell you right bro tell
me right at that time was his biggest
[ __ ] basalt basalt at that time was
Warren Street
oh how does it it was Warren Street and
Goldie Hawn lived there Oh a [ __ ] her
husband the dude from escape from
whatever lived there
it was just a small little [ __ ] town
go to booze funk now I don't even know I
can't imagine I heard Carbondale was
huge you know this is this forehead from
people but once he mentioned that song
at that time tell me where it was a
sleepy town and the rumor was that they
were getting the coke in Miami and how
they would drop it off and Miami was in
the mountains so he would take a plane
from Miami and drop it off in Colorado
because Colorado a little of everything
yeah you got Minneapolis you got [ __ ]
CNN a Las Vegas so they were dropping it
off and bumbles on top of mountains and
then they were storing it and they were
the rumor was Telluride was the hotspot
for it but I want to tell you why well
there was nothing I went back six years
later dawg it was [ __ ] human and
everybody was snorting coke just from
that so Hawk yeah it was there just from
him saying they hide it up and Telluride
Wow
how is world like where they're like
just weed dealers in these small sleepy
towns in the 60s and 70s and then we'd
coming coke and crack comes in and they
just they start hearing about it so they
start fire they find some way to get it
like how does this how does it like get
all that money
you look at these shows narcos and you
hear the numbers of what they were
sending in birthday truck and ridiculous
sending them by the Tonsley I know yeah
mm ton no container a town a ton is
2,000 yeah 1000 pounds that's that's a
thousand kilo so give it like whatever
because as a kilo is 32.2 which is
something like that surrounds in right
so 2.2 pounds that's little kilo is so
break it up down and you were selling
that in the United that was moving you
know when I was growing up I lived in
this area and that it runs from 7th
Street to 88th Street just in the Navy H
Street area
I remember six dealers that were doing
great yeah I know a couples that nobody
competed with nobody everybody was
making money another did everybody have
like their own block and [ __ ] normal
we had their own phone them okay and you
called them and they met you yes cool
whatever you know you had gone to high
school with him
and it was crazy and wicked took over
how quick people became because when
Scarface came out it just [ __ ] the
game up jack everybody wanted all colors
came out yes we're gonna do that now
when when colors came out the [ __ ]
cops went to the movie theaters yeah at
first weekend I'll never forget how is
out on bail look at the date of colors
release yeah the public was happy before
all gets to radiate okay I think it was
I was out on bail and I went to see that
movie and the arresting officer in the
case was playing security at the movie
theater no way I only saw me at the
movie dude he made like a face i he was
a tough girl I'm like [ __ ] you punk I
got this case beat [ __ ] yeah but that
movie pac-man capable 29th of all 88
yeah I was out on bail ready to get
sentence for kidnapping Ohio plea and
the guy the arresting officer was
working the detail at the movie theater
I went to what you think of the movie
colors yeah I liked it you know we had
them on the podcast Oh Willie Barcena
just had him on the pod oh yeah the cop
the Craig Hodges or the carpet that was
based off me
oh the real one yeah the cop that
what's-his-name rode around with to do
the the older guy or the young guy the
Sean Penn okay okay champagne yeah Sean
Penn's carapace we had a month Felicia's
podcast six years ago because he was
friends with a dude Felicia was dating
okay
he was really interesting you know what
he was saying what was going on yeah he
was a thing but y'all [ __ ] yeah ever
flies live over there then I lived off a
rampart and temple and we used to kick
it over there and it was [ __ ] it was
scary doll for me to say it was scary it
was scary like everybody was shady when
the cops are shady it makes the whole
hood shady because you got a battle the
cops now and then all these other shave
your [ __ ] enemies you I have
ever like la being itself scared the
[ __ ] out of me like when I came here in
84 I was 21 years old Wow Washington and
Vermont
my uncle still has a bar there on that
corner what is that like downtown LA
that's right before downtown Robert are
you on the way to courthouse in 84 that
was a [ __ ] zoo and I'm about you know
the biggest deception that you have
especially growing up in New Jersey of
California there was a beach herbage
baby yeah we got a bikini uh given you
on Burbank Boulevard and drive on the
other side of Lancashire it's still 1964
Bob Hope is walking those streets if you
get on Burbank you know like if you got
a Burbank Boulevard by lancashire and
then you cross Burbank Bruce we walk
those streets in those days that's all
martial arts [ __ ] the con the corner
that either they closed it or they about
to close it jingle bell is partners with
that martial arts of pilot fly store
it's the oldest martial art supply store
in California supposing I wanna write
then we could walk from here all we have
to do is walk the language and walk up
across a block and a half there's a
temple school next to it it's a Mexican
Kempo school the guys are great but they
teach in Spanish because everybody in
that school is basically Spanish okay
they're like [ __ ] I gotta lock that all
down but if you walk up that block you
like that well this is mighty 40 years
like when I came out and I saw
Washington remodeling
what the [ __ ] colorful is this [ __ ]
where's the punker you when you get off
the plane in Miami that's [ __ ] palm
trees everywhere yeah on the [ __ ]
Michael as a kid I used to land that
night and just to drive the smell the
sea air the ocean you're like Jesus I'm
in the [ __ ] ocean here where's
Aquaman you know when you get that way
he'll eat you land in LAX and you can
often you make those turns and you're
like what the [ __ ] have I done
the first now is beautiful they got palm
trees outside our asthma watch you get
the national [ __ ] century that [ __ ]
that McDonald's on the corner there
that that becomes real they got saying
you know what's crazy though the
craziest strip clubs all right by the
airport now dad you're gonna get your
dick sucked nobody wants that last
transportation your mama's home right
there
I was I was sitting there one day a
mobile or jab or and I'm gonna light
them my pearl look at this down here by
the airport they got thousands of
[ __ ] things in strip clubs yeah it's
the layover I imagine the layout yeah if
your plane gets canceled you know what
[ __ ] you take me over there to the
[ __ ] bitty titty and [ __ ]
yeah man strip club DJ lately has been
[ __ ] crazy Joey like right now all
these clubs do trump has affected
strippers like all the strippers now
they gotta pay taxes or become private
contract independent contractors so now
they're independent contractors it's
like no we don't work for them we just
borrow this facility you know what I
mean by that no okay so like if you're a
girl you can come in and be like all
right what's your contract I have to pay
this much if I make that much and I have
to work at this time or the later I show
up to work the more percentage I gotta
give so they're like I [ __ ] I'll show
up at 11 o'clock or 6:30
I'll pay 25% and whatever they make so
now it's their own company they're their
own company now so they can report
whatever they want to report because
we're just renting out the facility to
them all we do is charge 25 percent for
you to come and work here it's like uber
yeah so how does that affect you be the
part-time it's kind of like I mean it
doesn't if it's actually better for me
because other clubs will be like a 50%
off the [ __ ] top really I don't give
a [ __ ] for you know for the club so say
a girl makes a thousand bucks if you
make a thousand bucks where I work
twenty percent you you got to pay too
hundred if you workout another club you
got to give up for 250 so with me that
we take out last but they don't have to
stay or do anything and like these other
girls they have you on schedulers like
look you work here five days a week the
girls now they can just like you know a
[ __ ] I'm only working two three days
a week I'm a private contractor I show
up when I want to show up I'm paying you
to use your facility you know what I
mean by that so yeah man like it's been
off and on and when you DJ at a strip
club it's it's kind of like coaching
like you and this girl you get close
together you work with each other now
I'm working with chicks I want to run
their own scam that they run at other
clubs and [ __ ]
that whole like hey it's a two-for-one I
forgot to tell you like it what the [ __ ]
what do you mean you forgot to tell me
you could have charged that guy double
you know what I mean so it's affecting
the pocket but it's cool is a strip club
industry still as popular as it was I
mean some place always gonna be horny
[ __ ] yeah I mean there's always
fun crazy people now but look at they
got networks now Joey likes simple life
like save me you and Lee workers they go
to strip clubs they go to this network I
think it's called the hit it and quit it
and they tell you what I look if you go
to that club ask for that girl and like
there's an administrator that they have
to meet you at a club to let you in this
[ __ ] like network and they're always
at my club they even they gave me a good
review that like the DJ there's cool man
you don't trip because other clubs will
trip if you grab the girls titties on
the floor and [ __ ] or grab their ass us
we don't give a [ __ ]
we're one of the oldest clubs it's what
Paisley let's check this out no we can't
get in you have to be part of them it
doesn't go what you can't pay ninety
nine there's no you gotta meet that you
have to meet you have to be a customer
at the clubs that they're at and they
meet them so okay so I walk into a strip
club and I'm there for 20 men so
some blue comes up to me and says you
want to be part of in that one no way
he's gonna have to notice you had all
kinds of clubs like you know what I
should hit on my buddy well I mean I'm
gonna done a little I don't want to meet
nobody no you're not
[Music]
I'm just saying okay though so if a guy
sees me at my three or four school knows
you've been a lot strip club yeah yeah
doggy he's like yo man we got this
little networking [ __ ] that's crazy so
you can save money check it out this
club does seven full new dances on a
Thursday this one does five this one
does you know what I mean like you get
all the deals every club is trying to
out deal each other there's [ __ ]
clubs in City of Industry that are
giving you for lap dances for 60 bucks
Joey where that should be four times for
160 you'd make it my club did they're
fighting for dollar walk yeah it's fine
for a dollar like everybody else that
means that you man jobs
oh they're doing that means they're
[ __ ] freaking I used to let me rule
II used to have a room he had a really
[ __ ] good room Rudy for about three
months on a Wednesday night he had a
room in the City of Industry I'm it's
come you remember it I was right in
front of the strip club it was a fun of
the Hawaiian theater it wasn't a little
wizard father like that's a badass trip
it was deja vu or sin yes it was a
badass high level if there's six chicks
'working seven of them are throwing Heat
yeah nobody's pregnant
you don't everybody Joey that's changed
there's like 40 now 40 in there hey
remember me they're throwing more low in
heat at this place guys let me tell you
[ __ ] fucked-up story every time when
I went down there I was broke as dick I
know I know you came with the sack
because I know you will in a deal no no
no no listen to me in those days at my
addiction at that point was everything I
had I kept from myself
I only want to see utilities I want to
give you a line yeah my addiction was
out of [ __ ] control and I was
broke-ass and Rudy would call me and
he'd give me this small 40 and they fed
you know benjin like a nice [ __ ] meal
I was like an Irish pub it had a little
stage oh I remember him now
alright so was it Casey's something like
something like that it was a what 40
bucks on a Wednesday Tuesday night night
off it was an early show and had to be
in had to be done by 9:30 so cuz you
know he has to go to bed so he had to go
to bed something happen so I just start
dating Terry oh wow date about seven
months and Terry ain't stupid
she notices that when I got gigs I come
home busted so she's like where's the
[ __ ] money
that's one man she does you know what
I'm gonna take a ride down there with
Jim oh so she takes her right now she
drove her you drove she drove behind a
bicycle a [ __ ] bicycle to missing
tire what am I looking at and I get down
there with her and there's 14 people in
the audience
excuse me the next thing you know
something happens something happens some
drunk dude is really digging me I'm
working dirty and dirty and we really
don't like when you work there's no way
and I'm [ __ ] just going crazy on
stays this had to be guys mm this is 17
years ago oh I'm telling you guys I
didn't have a pot to piss in the manure
I was - ten thousand I was in deep debt
and I get there
and I'm picking up the small 40 from
Rudy but this dude says don't get off
the stage and takes his wallet and he
throws it up at me Wow grab it out of
the air and there's a bathroom right
next to the stage right so I do my
material like the guy's drunk with his
friend and a bunch of people and I
[ __ ] go what I get off the stage I
said thank you very much and they go
crazy but right they go hold on I got to
pee am I going to pee and help load the
wallet anything guys got like [ __ ]
nothing but yard sticks and head drain
that bit and I took like [ __ ] two or
three of them they put them in my pocket
and then he met me and gave me a hug
then I gave him back his wallet I made
believe what he was in my backpack away
he was not stea I go oh [ __ ] that's
right I gave it to him and I kept saying
no no [ __ ] why don't open the
wall and everything my wila get out of
here and then we got in the [ __ ] car
we got and nobody ever said nothing Ruby
never said nothing nobody ever said that
did she trip cuz you came home with a
lot of money probably knows nights you
know in 2000 in 2001 let me be honest
with you you know before you come to LA
people always say to you you never get a
job as a waiter you're not gonna make
any money let me tell you something guys
I got a job here in LA for the first six
months but I think I was rockin and
rollin if I would have been a normal
person like no addictions just paid rent
car payment insurance I could live here
for six months
I'm not lying to anybody no as a comic
as a stand-up comic cuz I was there was
a ton of commercials that the first
commercial I booked I boo so much money
bro I made so much well in seven or
eight months and then you didn't invest
it you did told it you'd invested I've
invested in Columbia that's what I
invested in I invested in Pablo Escobar
every dollar that [ __ ] it was it was
the first Taco Bell with the dog I was
getting checks I was I didn't have a
bank account I'd live
that Whitley in Hollywood Boulevard the
check cashing place and while all the
people in there they were just cashed my
checks all hours of the night Wow
but the other side of that coin is that
people always will tell you they're
gonna be able to make a living let me
tell you something guys when I got here
I did Tommy seven nights a week and I'm
gonna tell you something else I'm in a
minimum of twenty five hours and okay
just look at me go enjoy that's no money
but you said there was no money because
after three or four months like I got
here January of 97 but by December of 97
I had an apartment I was making a living
off fifteen dollar checks in the Comedy
Store The Improv gave you 750 the Laugh
Factory gave you 25 on Latino night and
everything else was from Jeff Garcia
Willie Barcena Felipe Esparza dr. Kidd
who became a born-again Christian had
rooms I mean the kid who still books
rooms great kid I forget what his name
is Sebastian 15 al everybody had three
room ice to hook you up to yeah you had
but this was one militarism they're
begging for calmly up in Northern
California oh yeah
in between Los Angeles and like San Jose
they're going crazy you know why because
20 years ago we were up there every
other [ __ ] month and some reason
every promoters stopped promoting up
there and they Grogan is not like a
third show in Fresno
no way yeah like that dawg it's crazy
there's nothing to do there's nothing to
do Fresno Bakersfield he's Bakersfield
that's one of my best shows every
breweries the best show I do every
[ __ ] year one of my shows it feels
weird all the people there they look
like they're on X Games and like Val
they are who gives a [ __ ] they laugh
they come out and they have a great
[ __ ] time yeah that [ __ ] breweries
right up there Bakersfield there is a
place out there in prison that it's like
they're not with Oildale were you by
Oildale dog in prison those
[ __ ] are like if the hills that
ice
people they walk around with no teeth
[ __ ] filthy Oildale you're being
oiled oh I don't know California yes
it's in Bakersfield bribe into some
places in California have been
imaginable unimaginable to shoot each
other I shot a Snickers commercial one
time uh-huh
three hours from here I had never seen
anything like that the hotel was in
Howell from the set guys and it was
nothing but flat and windstorms and it
was nothing but [ __ ] dirt guys when
we were sitting in the trailer gonna
shoot it was like the creepiest
environment I was out there like it's
like a desert it was somewhere [ __ ]
crazy alien India I'd been there's a
casino that Montoya used to book years
ago
Montoya men when they had the Management
Group yeah I think before you went away
they did when you got out of it they had
and he got clipped something happened
over there his management group booked a
casino and it paid and paid great money
it was it a New Mexico no it was no it
was four hours from here but something
again casino Marengo no it was not how
can and they I met here once a year
somebody goes I'm doing a shopping on my
they still do shows that because it was
shank chanting it was a four-hour drive
in the last hour was Hill you don't snow
you don't see nothing
you don't see nothing just all in and
all of a sudden you see a light and it's
like the Mad Max you know like the Mad
Max movies at night how oh yeah for in a
road warrior like out of the distance
you see like lights like people with
torches yeah like that's how the casino
was out there well yeah I think it's
probably when you're driving onto the
reservation right yes I mean the last
hour dog
you better have a full tank of gas and
you better not be hungry
- [ __ ] there is [ __ ] nothing
yeah they got a spot like that now
called the chunk Chauncey Andre
Covington their name yes he's always
he's cool shoutout to Andre cut yeah
yeah he was booking me and that's
another one for you 20 years ago
so like I'm Drake Covington has been
excuse me I've been here since 97 I
think Andre company Tim was giving me
work in 98 he was a DJ up and Fresno
still places he had the radio nation you
know he had comedy nights we were always
up there I just saw the guy in San Jose
the coach he wanted me to do single um
I'm already in Tempe okay what does he
he asked me know who doing a benefit it
would call me for the next one he used
to book something Bakersfield yeah next
to make this feel that was one of my
favorite drives when I had a gang up
north I knew one thing I was like ain't
good tacos because there's a place off
the road after for whatever Lord the 99
of the five something the five north you
could you drive 45 minutes out of here
you said taco truck on the side of the
road that's the one
little chubby Maxim doing his wife has
always had sitting around there I don't
know how many times I stopped in there
over the years we used to do all those
rooms I remember driving up to a Freddy
strode oh I'll share do a room that
Paymer say yeah like we would do that
that was your once in those days I was
going up north three times a month
and it paid good right-handers I did
great you would drive Mike Marino had a
room up there Mike Marino five-hour
drive deep into the heart of Texas you
got a hotel because it was fun and yeah
you ain't driving back yeah you ain't
driving back long for that so yeah once
you get the camera it's weird because
lifers changed the calorie I was like
okay if I could book myself in
California I'll just zip into Hawaii and
this was way before there was [ __ ]
make a turn
thirty miles yeah this was way before
that [ __ ] on a Thomas guide you had to
use a Thomas guy to measure it out and I
don't like [ __ ] going Jesus Christ
you know I booked myself in Norman chow
yeah but but uh but this is still five
or six hours from seven hours from
California like what happens like that
it's a law it's a big-ass state people
California is a [ __ ] long drive no
taxes will kill you but California is a
long [ __ ] Drive yeah it's way more
traffic more congested and you run into
crazy people the farther you [ __ ]
leave no you know let me tell what I
think bro is what I think I think that
driving is great I love her I love
driving you know for years I [ __ ]
throw my busting my hump in a [ __ ]
b210 Datsun I had a couple cars on my
[ __ ] Road but I will tell you
something then no matter what your plans
are there's one part Iowa this and you
get that way bro you could be 10 hours
ahead of schedule and LA will [ __ ] your
[ __ ] up by five hours oh yeah like I
start another one like getting a adorn a
Sunday night show and having to shoot my
way from Tempe and I had to be on the
set at 8:00 in the morning you came from
Arizona over here listen to me dawg
damn I [ __ ] drove I got off the stage
at Tempe at what what tons of feature
get off 8:30 but I went to a pizza place
together slice I hooked up with a chick
and we went back to a hotel can you
believe this [ __ ] this only happens when
you're gonna shoot a [ __ ] TV show
yeah this never happens when you have
the day off the next day no I remember
going I'm paying for a [ __ ] hotel
room I could have stayed in the [ __ ]
condo why did I even give back the
[ __ ] key I came to take it back to
the connector now god damn it and I left
the room at midnight you know I barely
managed to the second time be hours
and you're all dreams bro I got to this
I got the temp I got the LA at six I was
forty miles on la took like three
[ __ ] hours on a Monday morning that's
happened to me before man I remember you
remember things to have those gigs in El
Centro or like Brawley yes Mexico [ __ ]
yes oh Jesus Christ
yeah so we go do one out there and this
is I'm fresh off the MTV your mama
[ __ ] show us all
I got I'm young dog I got these young
chicks out there I end up hooking up
with the promoters daughter didn't even
know she was fine go back to the room
[ __ ] all night and I had to come home
and I think I had the audition I had to
do a local Comedy Jam for micro blitz at
the ice house and I was just a stand-in
somebody bombed and I got to get on it
was uh I don't to say his name you know
what I mean but uh I think this is 2003
2002 right when they filmed local Comedy
Jam scratch how many times are you on
local comedy jam again locals well I
barely got no shows yeah they hated me
they hated me doggone those shows I
could not in those days I was too dirty
for a Spanish audience there was still
Catholic right you know just be also
with the Piazza
[Music]
you look at that audience you look at
that audience and you watch my face what
cut cut to Italy he also promised land
Joey Diaz you watch this he just made it
look they if there was 600 people in
that 300 people hated me that night and
the hundred were just sitting there
going what the [ __ ] is this yeah Alex
hribal don't just went up there and did
a great job and when he danced with the
mask on something something had happened
and I went up there and just ate a bag
of dicks no well oh [ __ ]
watch it watch it I wouldn't lie to you
are you all watching they wanted a
picture no no what are we talking about
Italy
that's a comedy not really man that bong
had brought my toothpick back I'm tired
that's the bond of duck [ __ ] that [ __ ]
is strong
[Music]
what are you doing that anyone my dog's
I can't so calmly slow
[Music]
now I'm gonna have it
while they took it down no that's the
Gabriel one you did though you were
sweating bullets and now more when you
were in that soup no please
that's the most comfortable most
uncomfortable so I've ever been yeah you
just look sweaty I was just really
shocked at that the guy gave me a shot
uh-huh so doing show time was way
different from the Comedy Central one I
was a complete different person than I
did
I'll finally be on so calmly slim I did
not give a [ __ ] all right seriously you
just let's see let's compress starter
from scratch let me write it out for
none III know where let's go Joey Diaz
in capital letters again we're adults
here use capital letters for Christ's
sake apology it doesn't matter it just
please me all the time
he puts everything up there like a
[ __ ] half a MOOC yeah Joey Diaz nice
capital letters Jo ey these capital dia
see come on let's go say Joseph no Joey
Diaz capital o yah so P aya s o comedy
sled that's it alright biography last
time we ran down skin down see once they
got on there well yeah I mean one thing
it's a [ __ ] another
[Music]
one of the left fact I'll [ __ ] I'm on
now I'm getting done boys from my action
a B you go to the trailer dad put the
trail on I guarantee I'm not even the
[ __ ] down down down down the other
way right there there you go watch click
that watch I guarantee I'm the least of
the [ __ ] trailer watch the [ __ ]
hated me dog they [ __ ] hated me it
was hysterical I'm had a good time all I
gave a [ __ ] about was the to town not a
check huh I had a megabyte it away by
one to get my [ __ ] coke oh we were
where do we do that San Bernardino
Bernardino and remember they gave us a
hotel room yes there was an after-party
and then the game was to Showtime wine
bottle and you [ __ ] I'll give a [ __ ]
about that I gave that to somebody I got
my car like at that 2000 cash I was part
of my deal I want cash don't even think
about giving me a check hustling
paperwork would give me cash good on the
next lap out loud
George Wright welcome to buy also comedy
slam we are your FiOS for those of you
that don't know payaso is a Spanish word
which means clown we don't speak Spanish
I've said it before I'll say it again
time to learn [ __ ] by the way just so
you know we have we've gone all across
the country and we're bringing you
people from all across the country in
the first of a series called the final
comedy slam you're gonna see some guys
tonight from Los Angeles California
please make welcome mr. Eric Griffin a
lot of fools blew up on this though ugly
chicks should not be able to dress
[ __ ] walk over like hi ma'am hi yeah I
was standing over there and I just want
to let you look how long Mary Griffin's
better than ya guys on TV show vagina
who is about to drop that's hilarious
he knows you make fun of Asians don't
act like you don't they're not a drive
it's stupid
Asians we can't drive that's true but at
least we have car insurance
don't get mad member huh how many
[ __ ] one dying there's no you don't
put this on them ones it's time to sell
fast forward it to Joey he's all this
[ __ ] yeah I'm starting at the president
[ __ ]
[Applause]
and put me on my glass guy and I
guarantee ya fast forward it fast
forward he's after Jeff after Rick oh
they put me I'm telling you he is look
at the size of me Doug look at the
[ __ ] Perez tell you you have no
[ __ ] idea they went up there and I
was still hammered from the night before
like that it was Thanksgiving it was the
Friday after Thanksgiving by us now is
still [ __ ] up the night before
yeah John we got what the Belling at
7:00 in the morning I woke up that day
all I thought about was that 2000 [ __ ]
out I didn't get my material I didn't
think the thing was gonna make it to
Showtime I thought was just a [ __ ]
I think yeah [ __ ] it's not gonna make it
but you did show up early I've never
used like I said in a [ __ ] came early
you know if we had been lied to so much
at that time you know by that time I had
shot 50 things that were gonna be on HBO
and shelter Wow by the time I shot
payaso comedy slam how many [ __ ]
things do you think did you see what I
put up here they Rafi ellos pizza did
you see that video I show and pull up
nice I learned something here then close
Junior one Rafi ellos pizza oh yeah
you know I shot 80 things that dude
already talked to the dude at HBO there
was gonna go to any of eight episodes
we're just waiting come on down to the
first one tonight for free or 200 or 300
you worked all day like a [ __ ] slave
and three months later you got a call
that you know anybody at YouTube what
are you talking about talking about you
told me you know people next thing I
know your stupid thing is on fine
YouTube we did 23 years ago you normally
[ __ ] things I did that was supposed
to [ __ ] be on CBS and NBC and you
have no identified I'm supposed to call
this act ahead Quinn being him dinner
her faith Law & Order during the strike
the guys from wall on SVU got together
and shot a miniseries and you passed a
picket line and they were supposed to
die we shot it for something I think we
shot it for free it was far okay the
matter with you you know cross to pick
along the Union Foreman knowing if I was
a danger home with you you [ __ ]
delegate so no it was weird that we shot
and that was gonna be in law and order
and about a year ago I saw it on YouTube
somebody sent me this and said this is
you I was like things that I do
Netflix has two things out
I'm on Netflix somebody emailed me the
other day and said joy I was watching
Sun and you came on yeah you're on War
Philippe we play a cop yes that's a
horrid horrid movie and I was addicted
to real special seedpod now you'd love
you and you got a blessed Nick you got a
blessed mikta tune what was he like a
zillion
dictatorial got these poor Filipino
family that wanted to make movie buck
buck does he don't give a [ __ ] [ __ ]
accessorize a [ __ ] Savage I will tell
you that about him and that's what made
me fall in love that's why I put him on
the back
because when Nick is determined to do
something he bites into it New York stop
but there's always a by the way yeah
always on your behalf but you're happy
like for that movie we got sag I'm for
song yay today
Wow or 68 a day what does that mean four
hundred sixty bucks for eight hours yeah
for sixty four hours issues a scale was
like so whatever scale is now they feed
you and all that [ __ ] who the same scale
it was only 469 a day I won't even have
to audition he told me to grow a
mustache looks like will grow a mustache
so I had to put a fake hold on it it's
just the worst thing you will receive
the director how we remember now my god
the director had a wig and it was mixed
with his hair and the window blow on
another place where the wind was blowing
and there was a Nicollet or a special
his whole family's in the movie you know
the cousins the Filipino family was in
the movie it was [ __ ] hilarious
we like I said he paid us you know who I
met on that that was very nice the best
part about that whole [ __ ] shoot was
that I got to meet that dude that came
out of prison on The Sopranos and caused
a lot of problems
I'll pick up real a prio not Jackie up
real
I don't know that Jackie appealed the
route again go to youtube please what
are you got anger in there gives a shout
outs where you go to youtube Sopranos
Gandolfini's best scenes let's give a
shout out to my girl Lizzie Durazo
having a hard time she wrote an article
but at the BuzzFeed i retweeted Rogen
everybody between it
how about ties sick gal Barry Nathan Cox
bird snake Brown Chris Gonzales will
brown down there in Sydney
Evan Mason 32 and resilient castaway I
love you [ __ ] don't forget
stand-up live in Alabama March 1st 2nd
and 3rd and then level II live in Nyack
New York March 21st on a Wednesday
[ __ ] night
8 o'clock [ __ ] if you right there
that dude the seconds put that right
right there that dude this was the
funniest thing I did on this movie was I
hooked up with this dude oh yeah he was
cool
what was he the producer
[Music]
well the [ __ ] is yelling your tenant
fell fast forward this guy here was a
bad he's in some [ __ ] old-school
movie right they write that everything
umbrellas click the backwards good keep
going
right there right there everyone's kind
of story head of the line I've been
aligned for 10 [ __ ] years
uncle's just asked if what my father
would have given him if he was boss from
Richie got out of prison and I had
nothing to do what they were brothers
you respected my father's respect Richie
those who I'm respect give respect
see he just told you to shut the [ __ ] up
Eddie don't mean go [ __ ] myself
I thought we spent three days together
the first day he was talking about he
didn't get high whatever
I dropped the metal albums I [ __ ] him
up this is my way before there was legal
this is when you didn't know for sure
ah see how strong it was and people put
xanax and Alicia you would get [ __ ] up
jack
I gave him that a boy he came back the
next day he's like where do you get a
medical marijuana license oh my god is
that way you got killed off the show did
you get I'm like addicted to weed or
something because you couldn't remember
anyway we got so [ __ ] up on that set
but the director had the worst week ever
but Felipe the producer fell over Felipe
so he invested in a fully traceable okay
was he like a sheriff in that movie too
Oh Felipe because he had a hat on too
and [ __ ] yes he was a sheriff
it is the worst of Pico ELISA is the
worst movie of all [ __ ] time but you
know what you guys would be good like in
a cop dude like a lethal weapon with you
and Felipe no who's a killer laughter
did you like heroin nobody down that's
never gonna work
there's a scene in [ __ ] and Lethal
Weapon where he runs from Hollywood and
Vine to the 101 Oh in three minutes
nobody could do that maybe yelling
escape what's that see it's interesting
that you live like Fabien Lee where from
somewhere else so when you watch that
like we I loved watching SWAT all those
movies that they remain because they
shot them in my neighborhood and when I
lived in that neighborhood Oh like
pretty web all right if you watch pretty
women now you're like what the [ __ ]
la Hollywood this still places denim you
know that place ain't there now I don't
think it's there but did that that
location is still like everything still
when
oh there's a movie called valley girl
about a girl who lives in the valley and
they - dude they go in the Holly with
one of my all-time favorite [ __ ]
movies it's a great war with Nicolas
Cage and the blonde chick disappeared
but if you watch it they show places and
you just like do pause on Ventura which
is on the constructional they closed it
down
I do pause was [ __ ] huge back was
that Club Oh breakfast place but at that
time see if there's a valley girl
see if there's a cook valley girl this
haha how does the world and where were
you
I see the difference and I gotta see it
well you did it come out bro
eighty [ __ ] - that's a foundation
credit right there foundation guards was
let go
valley girl that's fine that's fine girl
GI L don't come up like a stronger Sun
for watching and you don't even smell
that for it it was laughs but it was you
your Park was loud but your bite was a
vision I still got it
still hungry oh my god
Lee I did that once when I was a Tweaker
this this girl was like send me your
number and I spelt it out as a valley
girl why why is it valley girl
that's it right there with ya there goes
Kay's classic 1983 bro this is this is
still one of my on my five movies bro
there's this like 10 scene in this movie
that could destroy me and the [ __ ]
father
is the chef on her Apocalypse Now oh
yeah yeah he plays a STONER with the
mother she's a hippie and Nicolas Cage
is [ __ ] tremendous see if you get the
volume on this lien how I was gonna take
to get to the meeting it's a problem
you're in charge of home you look at all
this place that's the ball we that's the
ball right by house yeah look at yeah
okay look at that Lea that's the [ __ ]
ball by your house Lou she's out there
somewhere
this is the story of a boy oh my god I
give it more this one all-time favorite
movies those why down here cuz they're
from the valley and these guys are so
[ __ ] Hollywood look how cute this
girl is when I was 18 you have to be are
you kidding this is my fantasy guys but
I was gonna come out of here we shall be
the [ __ ] regular white girls normal
life is [ __ ] storm watch Hollywood look
at how it look for Jam damn look at
Hollywood look
alright like the girl from the car save
the radio then they go to Hollywood
[Applause]
he takes a girl from the valley from the
valley to [ __ ] Hollywood um saying I
said I'd do that y'all I didn't come
down here you freak um doubt that they
haze it her brain being her girlfriend
Taylor then she changed up on them
because he changed and the people who
try to pull them apart like this do was
a big strong
look over there are sharp in life if you
think she's confused you should see her
father cool watch this [ __ ] she's from
the valley know what your piece is this
is the [ __ ] dog dojo Danna the mountain
track looks bad all those tremendous dog
and it's getting better all the time
there's nothing you and I won't do
are you [ __ ] nut here we go here we
go is even movie clips when I watch it
no I want to sit here and look at you
yeah Dan that hot dog on a stick
that's the [ __ ] that's where we go
now wait how many times have you been
there that's why girls like that when
you got here this is 1982 [ __ ] three
I got hearing oh the night you found
okay ninety-seven even though girls talk
like this I don't know I believed it dog
I'm from Jersey
yeah this is my fantasy become I hear
meet one of these broads and hang out I
[ __ ] go to the valley and go to
Hollywood they go to a bunch of [ __ ]
cool places man and that's what happens
they go to the beach and she meets rocky
and Nicolas Cage at the beach and then
Nicolas Cage won't leave her alone he
hooks up with her she breaks up with her
boyfriend and then [ __ ] The Hoff
friends turn on the list to do with the
red shirt that's her boyfriend
three little punks straight out Buster's
see but she dumps him who [ __ ] look
at his lame ass so all the girlfriends
are in love with the dude with the red
shirt what's my problem
touch your days and no phone call the
bus
so all that girl phones want to suck
this guy's dick she got the Woody
Woodpecker pin though dog she said
there's a cute girl she's a virgin yeah
is what you want if she done with a tank
gave him the bracelet don't look at the
dog
when your dog Julie white shirt or the
valve you can touch me I mean she must
be really freaking out there's all crazy
Hollywood like the ghetto to the valley
I don't lie did Olivia I don't know it
was like the valley must have been you
know I read something interesting the
other day that one
they banned they banned what's the dude
that I went to the one-man show when
they ban blending blue Lenny Bruce oh
all the clubs in the valley
no they banned them from everywhere in
the country okay I know that only place
he could work out was in the valley Oh
in the San Fernando Valley how [ __ ]
weird is that like this was there was a
bunch of strip clubs up here and up here
he could be liberal you know up here he
could be free he wasn't Hollywood he
wasn't a real uptight people yeah he was
up here and he just I just read this
maybe on Wikipedia maybe a couple weeks
ago last week I went to a one-man show
so it had to be a couple days after that
I was up late one night and just ran up
about oh [ __ ] was pretty interesting
then the valley was don't have watch
this when I was like 19 and it was a
fantasy of mine like I mean I loved that
boy at 19
there was no yeah in my life George dog
I probably was the least things oh my
[ __ ] mind that I thought and now I
know it I remember remember you remember
that movie just one of the guys you know
who's in that movie oh my friend Georgie
paladin ski
oh yeah my brother thought I was my
movie where the girl [ __ ] cuts her
hair becomes a dude and a rat for the
school paper
he has they shot that in New Jersey and
he was all they did that was his claim
to fame for about four years he would
have been the guy that bought the pets
in the shower he had a scene in [ __ ] it
in fact let's call him up and see what
he says watch
that's crazy this is crazy watch just to
show you people uncle Joey [ __ ] around
connected connected man I'm [ __ ] up
that shrooms was nice
ya know when you smoke those shrooms
it's a [ __ ] killer that's a different
hi look at leas looking at me all weird
he took like ten hits he never even knew
he kept looking at the wrong hand you
don't know I'm a magician from [ __ ]
death
I had already mixed it in plus I put it
something and he edible too I sprinkled
this I stuck the stump in the attaboy
you know you gotta watch me like a hawk
Lisa super magician you know yeah man
this [ __ ] made my teeth hurt again but
it feels good it was funny Ali sittings
friend last night this is a podcast and
it just got up and said Kim can't
control those out of old man can't
control those edibles watch I'll call
him up and say hey [ __ ] ass my
father's [ __ ] I'm gonna be pissed off
for your resents gotta be laid up what
time is it 9:30 girlfriend's house
[ __ ] doing some you shouldn't be
doing I'll keep calling until he picks
up you know Ellen you better pick up
that phone [ __ ] cuz I'm gonna call
you back here we go watchband
boom I'll call him tuna and I will
torment this [ __ ] he will know what
the [ __ ] him see this is old-school [ __ ]
back in the days you would call to a
[ __ ] answered I will [ __ ]
call you until
[Music]
that's how we used to get your attention
in the old days they have [ __ ] caller
ID no nobody had caller ID what about
that [ __ ] emergency breakthrough I
mean I've never you who used an
emergency breakthrough what's up that's
worse
you pay the like you push a special
number you call the operator until
operator hey I'm calling the phone that
doesn't have double line so I need to do
an emergency breakthrough I guess is
they charge $5 by god that was a long
time ago yeah right that's way before
least time Lee wouldn't even understand
so let's say you want the following your
girlfriend okay and I kept trying to
call your [ __ ] phone and your phone
was busy for an hour and I was your
dad's boss
I can call the operator and go I need to
do a [ __ ] emergency breakthrough and
you'd be talking to your girlfriend yeah
so maybe we'll go on Yelp and pick a
Mexican restaurant let me tell you
something that operator would come on
and go excuse me is there somebody named
Lee Sang okay yes I'm just trying to
call your father get off the phone
yeah and they would [ __ ] call back
and tell your father they've been
calling for an hour you get your [ __ ]
ass whipped
cuz the operator would throw you under
the bus you think I'm kidding yeah
that's old school League can you imagine
up on the phone with your little
girlfriend tell them I stuck on the tix
on Saturday after the dance and also the
operator cut sitting does excuse me
yeah that's old school [ __ ] oh my god I
forgot all about that [ __ ] I said that's
that original [ __ ] stalker huh when
she breaks to him ever going and paying
the phone bill I've done that to in 19 I
think that I started paying the phone
bill for my mother when I was about
seven and you need to City the bar phone
bill I'd have to go around the corner
and then sometimes she'd make me walk
from North Bergen up that hill to pay
the [ __ ] phone bill when it was close
to a place called a four-star diner
across from a theater I'm thinking of
doing this is in Jersey future yang
Union City and I used to pay the phone
bill there that was the way this thing
and you got had a going in get the
the court like if you talk [ __ ] because
the cords were look at the saffron I
understand you exact so in those days
let's pretend I shared a room with Lee I
don't want to lead listen to my
conversations with my girlfriend so I'll
take the phone
drag it as far as I could and then I got
a longer wire from the phone to the
other end of the [ __ ] connector
uh-huh so I could walk 20 feet with it
and talk on the phone so leave with him
my conversation how crazy was that used
to have to get a long cord
I remember those you know what I
remember Joey laughs this generally
you'll never do you limber if only oh
yeah of course I had I had a rotary
front of my house I'm not that young I
didn't know for sure yeah I'll [ __ ]
operator will call that's right yeah I
remember him I would love my parents to
take me to the bank to cash her check
because they had a waning lobby to have
crackers cook like the the taffy
crackers like cooking me be a Mets got I
never had a cream puff before lollipop
yeah everybody had lollipops no you
weren't kid who walked into a business
you had I bought my daughter a jacket it
was the place going out of business on
the way out you don't want a lollipop
and I looked at the lady I liked the
lady a lot I really liked how she
treated my daughter like more old-school
gangster
yeah like old-school gangster anybody
could sell clothes
anybody could sell you clothes have you
ever been have you been taken by a
clothes salesman yeah real close
I've been waiting takes you to the point
where you sign up for a [ __ ] his
credit camera like bro there was a dude
one time that took me to the cleaners
and I was so overwhelmed by him that I
became his friend the sad thing is I own
200 bucks
since 1995 you all returned my calls I
hunted him down for 20 years because he
was a very very very dear friend of mine
and he sold close to you he was a close
self and he was from he was a Jewish kid
from the Bronx
braum and he was the epitome of what a
Salesman was smoothly made you over
you'll never understand what a real
clothes salesman is like when I was a
child and I came from tree you know I
lived on 205 West 88th Street on 86th
Street and Broadway there was a a men's
clothing Shore shoe store Paul Briggs
every time I saw old from time to time
as a goof my mother would take me in
there to measure my foot can get shoes
and there was an experience like it
wasn't going to foot walk when some kid
just throwing six pegs my pad six and a
half in front of your feet and you got
to try them on it in the 70s they did
everything for you then I Taylor imagine
that God they sat down first they got
you up and they measured your foot and
they [ __ ] took your dead [ __ ] sock
off and they put like a party sock on
what Spanish people call party songs
with inside yeah they make the different
shoes I think I would come back with 18
pair of shoes he was gonna sell you
something yes but when you got up how he
put the shoe on how he pee used a
shoehorn
the look his touch I remember that now
he would say to you you look beautiful
with that shoe on and you were invented
by one shoe be into the mine three
because he's a Salesman he knows how to
make you feel well so I go with my
daughter torn apart and we meet up with
my friend Wall Street tomorrow or a
ballet and then every Saturday is what I
do I think you know and we take him to a
park in there play and then we're gonna
eat somewhere we hang out so it would be
pizzas afterward I have a lady yogurt
and I wasn't got a frozen yogurt case
you could put a bunch of fruit in it and
you could feel full for Weight Watchers
so I went to a yogurt store and that's
what I do I get like a little
yoga but to rest the strawberries I
don't get the lollies on the bananas
that the bananas are fresh I get bananas
and I just love bananas
Oh with yogurt and [ __ ] just a plain
low-fat yogurt and he ever gives me that
casket on a Gascon oh how was that I
think that with the Cubans fry the
bananas
chicharrón is the fried pork taco oh
yeah proctologist for how Puerto Ricans
say yeah yeah yeah Reese had fried
bananas I took him down there he's lost
his [ __ ] mind
he's had skew and food down there Lyle
culture they don't you know how I don't
are we saying oh it's honor myself we're
talking about the salesmen how you got
his shoes then he would put your shoe on
resistible says what happened like my
daughter is five you know leave yogurt
let's see you look at that son now every
time I go to that yogurt spot it's at
night when I get bored at night like a
points left
I go glass so I fill up at about 8
o'clock I just take a ride over there
stoned I doubled hardly thought bass and
I going there and that place is open
till 11:00 I didn't know that the lethal
but when you go in the daytime there's a
woman's clothing straw that but the half
of it is for kids I'm talking about
badass [ __ ] like just bangin yeah so
with Sydney the yellow is you know damn
look at that Jack and I look like a holy
[ __ ] that's a badass jacket and she goes
when we finish the yellow can we go in
there oh yeah ain't no one there
and we went and well she went in and the
lady [ __ ] got up and instead of
coming to me she went right to my
daughter has two selves who knows how
are you doing today
if it wasn't anything you looking for my
daughter
that jacket it was quick are you
watching like it I'm watching this whole
interaction her daughter's acting yes I
thought it comes in dressed to the nines
with a phone you know looking beautiful
as she does with that little Logan the
lady came up to him just but she just
made her feel like usually Marissa will
stand next to me and look at me not this
time
where she looked directly average
because how are you doing today good
there's something I could show him and
she treated one sick of it I got a dump
yes I'm gonna show you
it wears a med check it and she goes
okay come with me let's take this jacket
off here first
hold my god you have such beautiful hair
let's push it back ah
then she walked her over and she took
the jacket off champion I can't belong
to a [ __ ] princess like she left it
all that on are you ready are you ready
and then she was like yes yes yes it
feels hold on let's put it on in front
of the mirror yeah they don't do that at
Marshall's no way don't do that no
where'd you understand me now I'm
standing there right now I have anxiety
things are how it starts now the only
reason why I went in there because of
the sign the place is going out of
business me and I know it's 50% off plus
I can negotiate it
oh yeah which I never do but if I had
like 60 bucks cash in my pocket right
like I expected it to be like [ __ ] 80
boxes in there and Sherlock tis one of
those three-way mirrors now the jacket
emergency that she took her hair that
she locked it up on Mercy and it fit her
like a [ __ ] glove and it with a
little [ __ ] button on the side did
you see le no a minion
beautiful so she puts it on it's a mink
pink mink like a princess thing it's
beautiful and she goes what do you think
and merciless as yours I'll take it I
looked at her and I go are you sure this
is what you want
and she goes yes eating mommy like you
know she worked me on but do you think
mommy I got mom I got a second I will
just tell you need a jacket POC grandma
yeah yeah anything no there was no dress
so whatever I knew fit I was gorgeous my
daughter looked and she goes no I'm
gonna go with the jacket
the lady pushed a bunch of buttons bro
is 38 house know where I spent $38 on
stupidity every [ __ ] day my man just
train up the lady looks at my daughter's
she goes it's hot out there
you want to wear down my knowing goes
yes what do they listen it was a good
choice is 90 degrees it is been [ __ ]
rain come walking around like Elizabeth
Taylor
up in the [ __ ] Valley I'm [ __ ]
bird back on a low Canyon Boulevard we
walk in the house my wife tries to like
say Guerra like boo she goes oh I was
like boo what do you have jacket they go
see grandma wow I just looked at me like
Jesus [ __ ] Christ no time he was 30 he
[ __ ] dollars and the lady gave her
all the attention or tears were walking
up the bush was excuse me young girl do
you want a lolly about and if he looks
at me shoot any other lawyer yeah they
don't I probably she walked up to her
and she gave her a lollipop and I go
give her a hug and she gave her a big
house Allah
solid she walked out there like a little
young lady ha ha yeah listen brah was
learned I was taught to interact
early on when well I mean no no
distinction that [ __ ]
I hacked because I was always around
adults mm-hmm I know what you mean
though I was always around adults at
that age my father had died when I was
five like I was watching Bronx Tale five
two weeks ago was on AMC three times in
one weekend I kept watching it and I
still remember like being a kid and
walking to the corner to get an Italian
eyes and being five like would you let
your kid walk fifty yards on Tremont
Avenue in the Bronx in 1968 this is 90
they knew who you were they didn't know
what the [ __ ] I was I was just a little
[ __ ] scared kid with a dollar bill in
my head running your mom my mother would
stand there and go run to the corner get
the Italian ice and run right the [ __ ]
back don't make one thing catch that
that's a training she was exactly doing
supposed to like hey I'm watching and
someone comes I got your back but
besides that go get that [ __ ] come to me
that tell me would you take your
daughter right now no not right now but
in our time it doesn't matter whose
voice sacrified yam I'm no no no no my
mom would have done that with me whether
I was a boy or girl my mom yeah they
believed in toughen you up an early age
making you a value of money like she
knows something happened I told you
gotta work three hours and guess what
she's been asking me lately
no yeah ain't only hood in your office
and dude work just fix the album yeah
thank you for the wall ah [ __ ] yeah I
got a ten year old Joey and she's
getting at that age now like we went to
Target and she wanted these overalls out
were kind of short and [ __ ] and she
looked at me she goes I don't think
you're fair what do you mean I'm not
fresh because you asked me for my
opinion for how I want to style myself
and you know what mean that being
understood that's you know what we're
not gonna hear none of this [ __ ] no more
let's go we're leaving so we're waiting
in the Starbucks line and I try to give
her a hug Joey and she brushed me off
like oh [ __ ] off me they're hurt I was
like what's wrong and she goes you still
think I'm five and I was like what do
you mean she's like you you don't let me
be I'm gonna be in sixth grade next year
look it show me pictures of her friends
with the shorts on miles alright cool
I didn't know my daughter was slick like
me dog they were the shorts like you see
how my shoes they if mice they fold over
yeah she try to fold them up two more
times they make them shorter like her
friends and [ __ ] and the teacher called
me up she goes eh I know how you are she
she wormed a school but she had a backup
pair of pants in her backpack that's
what pissed me off I go hey man if you
were down to wear those overalls with no
backup I would have believed it but you
knew what you're doing was wrong why did
you bring the backup pants like you know
what I mean you left the house with
those pants and then you put those
overalls on it [ __ ] me up dog
I made me think like damn who's my
daughter trying to impress out there is
there another sixth grader in sheds are
full so I just had that crazy talk with
her let me know how guys are I said look
your daddy was one of those bad guys I
know how we are do you have to protect
it's crazy dog she's tanned I'm flipping
out is that the age yeah I don't know
what the ages of them all you know yeah
she has a cell phone now all that [ __ ]
it's a different world out there you
know it is the pressure it's a different
[ __ ] world I can't imagine I cherish
the days I have with her that'll she's
five oh that's why I worked the schedule
that I worked mm-hmm that's why I act
how I act I put the commitment I can
into it I try to make these events and
you know they switch them with it should
they called me today a 5-2 switch my
date alone
well I said
the best that's okay I need to do it you
need to do but I gotta be up here by
4:15 you know to take this [ __ ] first
ballet thing his paxil sir
that's what song Tuesday Wednesdays and
Thursdays if I'm in town there's what he
to doing Saturday is making it my wife a
break plus I need to see Ron Sally's
hair long run for hours three hours you
know and then dog let me tell you
something I was wiped out this Monday I
kept thinkin god damn I'm getting
[ __ ] old but no I spent like the
Sunday I [ __ ] took a nap and I woke up
at 4:00 and she was right there waiting
for a sugar daddy are we gonna park him
Wow died of laughter called you out so I
took her to the park and we walked I go
this walk [ __ ] it
you know I'll get some weight watcher
points and I just walked with her and I
got to the park and there was really no
kids dead so guess what guess Lester
picked her up 18 times yeah and put her
on the zip line
I got she's lovely I give a [ __ ] to walk
quickly up but then you gotta push him
on the double-barrel swing when they get
their buddies to do it bro I was putting
the tents on my back every day the last
[ __ ] hammered this morning has
grinding it off because it was too much
pushing boat it's [ __ ] now if you come
to me and said what would you rather go
two hours per father your daughter at
the party like I don't think about that
[ __ ] yeah I really yeah 5500 well Monday
nah 50 [ __ ] five damn so I'm trying
to recover my body I got no matter what
I do is I go to jujitsu what do
kettlebells or whatever I got four days
a weekend me that maybe three quite last
we got worked out five times I'm gonna
pay for that not all yeah but the next
so maybe like one when I go to Denver I
just do bodyweight [ __ ] because you
can't breathe anyway they hit out I'm
doing yeah but I already got people
they're planning on assassinating Levi
there will be some [ __ ] edibles in
just some American ninja trophy has no
idea we thought is no idea Lee hey Joey
you know you don't notice in my forties
man that like well in my twenties and
thirties I I slept a lot and I'm not
sleeping as much as I used to like this
last night I had a dream and when I woke
up from that dream I carried into the
same dream twice again dog and it was I
rented out my back house to a pastor I
didn't know he was a pastor and he found
out that I was [ __ ] strippers and
smoking weed in my house and that full
ran through my house so I went back
there and I shot his family up it was
love dreams we have problems no duh but
I can't waking up and going back into
the dream it was weird
I'm shooting him again again yeah it was
like don't help me I live my life yeah
we got [ __ ] high last night and for
some reason I hope I got [ __ ] higher
I had the hello know when I went crazy I
bought this box away watch it protein
bars did two points of peace
I ain't no whole [ __ ] box I got so
[ __ ] high and then I just did some
crazy show has been my last night I was
out of my mind like how I don't know
what the [ __ ] was those animals last
night I was like I don't know one of us
didn't know finally I went to bed I was
so high away there's a eight times the
recommended dose and one gives a [ __ ]
you gotta take a chance but I went to
bed that I had rattling restless leg sir
Oh bring your legs get
my legs get [ __ ] going crazy in the
middle of life dog I couldn't know I had
a [ __ ] up day yesterday in Hollywood I
did the Stella Adler theater they put a
show there it was dope PAC killed did 20
minutes killed came outside thought I
was smoother than the [ __ ]
parking attendant they told my car I was
like oh my god so I asked you know you
know security guards always show up
after you should get towed he came out I
told you not to park their dogs I was
like honey you just say should I even
ask you if he was cool
he's like I thought she was in the white
one you look like you have that car that
car you got told it look like yours so
it I went to the [ __ ] tow station
wizard off a millstone or something
right there in Hollywood yeah 10:15
millstone yeah I called them they're
like your car's not even here yet like I
missed it by five minutes to 82 to get
my [ __ ] car then I will I go to the
comedy store cuz you know I need a drink
I need [ __ ] I almost got a [ __ ] toe
tag and uh cause I was so heated I
forgot to pay the meter oh my god ow
and then I had that crazy dream about
killing the priest I live behind me it's
time to go talk to somebody maybe like
you that they really give you them but
no I don't even [ __ ] dream I get so
high sleep I wake up when I realized
what a [ __ ] am I and what do I have to
do do I have to get on stage tonight why
am i running away for a comedy show we
get so [ __ ] high sometimes yeah as I
said were you like that in the old days
Joey what do you mean
cuz I remember sometimes they'd be like
a dog Joey might not remember if he's
Philippe it'd be like fool I forgot to
remind of me I don't know he's gonna
come tonight cuz he forgets would you
forget to go to shows cuz you're so
[ __ ] up no it depends on my
okay okay Oh finally checking a man
white for 300 from residual and it was
Wednesday and you had a gig for me in
orange
uh uh it was $20 yeah and I already got
my coat for the day I wasn't showing up
I love dish it early something was gonna
happen dog you're not gonna believe it
I got a flat tire on my car three went
down in LA sure like the best driver got
pulled over you eat my cocaine use made
me so undependable my putt 2005 to 2007
the [ __ ] I was doing was just that did
you ever feel like you know what I you
know [ __ ] made me stop a little as I
felt a heartache come a heart-attack
come but it was like I had my heart was
hurting but then I could feel like my
kidney mad at my heart like a [ __ ] I'm
more [ __ ] up than you why do you want
all this attention like you ever get
those sharp pains as I was getting them
in my spine and my neck okay like what's
that from whoa that means something's
coming down keep doing what you're doing
this is not gonna be good okay your body
giving you a warning before you wake up
to the hospital one day and they'll like
you OD door you had a mild heart attack
or you had a heart attack but you had a
stroke or you know that that that's what
that is
it must have happened four or five times
to me yeah like it's scary huh yeah like
once you told your dad went to work out
I was hitting the bag that was early I'm
working I'm working on we're gonna know
I'm doing the guys told me to do and
don't there was a point there that I was
like whoa hold on one second I felt [ __ ]
missing beats yeah I just walked and
breathe and focus on my breath you know
and I when I was doing drugs the devil
nights I don't mind always gonna [ __ ]
blow up I thought yeah dude I know that
feeling if you hold it - huh - even hole
in it you ever been in a bed laying in
the but the whole bed is fine I've been
in the bed that have no idea what's
likely the lay in the bed and the bed is
vibrating from your heart yeah and your
heart it's [ __ ] pounding in your
chest you dick can't get hard now you're
[ __ ] higher than [ __ ] you got another
2 or 3 grams on the room you got another
corner outs in the car and you ain't
stopping your heart is [ __ ] pounded
and it's telling you another one and
you're trying no you're smoking
cigarettes you're up there you have no
idea I was laying on a blanket on the
floor and I thought that I was on a bed
and it was pounding like the blanket
made me feel like I was on a bad
pounding scary [ __ ] so do you got going
on g-man oh you really scare these poor
people they're supposed to Tom Prison
stories I mean I say what we have a good
[ __ ] I come alone
hey chill Allah you got to see your boy
Lee Bobby got the single mushroom
Lucille now rang we single he [ __ ]
done that's it he's slinging dick and
giving out chocolate bars yeah he's got
a hot date tomorrow I heard through the
grapevine that things are happening for
some and I wish he's gonna throw his
show on Venice you know what let's take
him to the strip club tonight not
tonight
no too [ __ ] up to go there he is yo yo
yeah dawg I got a guy here that's saying
that one of his favorite movies growing
up was just one of the guys and I told
that that was your big screen debut and
[ __ ] I'm saying oh baby it's you alright
sorry about that
I thought you played here saying I'm
going to try to promote you get your
movies [ __ ] and you gotta [ __ ] it up but
baby it's you [ __ ] and which one
what was it who's a baby it's you
I thought you haven't seen your dad but
Donna Julie right and you didn't a ball
with him then you went to the strip club
[Applause]
yeah like good-looking do it
he was also another alphabet city look
at George Khalid in ski dropping
knowledge on a [ __ ] what's the name
of the framing company in close eye part
F and B frames in Cliffside Park
if you leave your frame and done they
got a bunch of Joey Diaz memorabilia in
there if you could call him on the
[ __ ] hotline as for George he's got
merch for you to buy he's got [ __ ] from
The Longest Yard and many other sets
that I burglarized all right right there
you know I'm thinking all the eBay and
that George got the goods
don't hide if he ain't got him don't
worry you'll get them you have 18
million bushels tomorrow who gives a
[ __ ] mind your business view I'm trying
to blow him up here like I thought I
would all right I'll call you tomorrow
brother stay black I love you hey I
would have called you back to LA yo Dawg
what's up it's late I know you gotta
call people late let them know you I
keep them in check from time to time my
body [ __ ] the one that son is I
usually call them at this time of the
night don't wake him up hysterical he
just does his way until your [ __ ]
heart Tommy this one it's that way this
mama Lou called me Jesus Christ Electra
so I saw that in August you're doing the
[ __ ] yeah jam with [ __ ] sky I'm
doing a funk fest and
August at the Anaheim Honda Center that
Saturday August 4th I'm doing it with
Jorge from curious entertainment it's
gonna be Morris day in the time the
bar-kays dad's band consumption climax
original menu whole thing is I'm hosting
it I meant seeing him between between
Donnie everybody does to its owns yeah I
know they do know they do like eight and
if you only have two you go in the
beginning a lot of them like Howard
Johnson's sky Evelyn champagne the sky's
got to James yeah they're paying got
three jams
yeah yeah a shame but you know what they
do now is they sing other people's [ __ ]
I don't want to hear that yeah I'll get
we all [ __ ] up legal sing me a bunch
of songs roof also February 27th I'm at
the Brea improv headlining with Sam
Tripoli this is all a talk we're just
talking about two guys that don't quit
that you dude that's why I love you yeah
that's what I'm happy you could show up
on the show tonight
not only that tonight's the first time I
get to introduce Ben Sarah watches to my
audience listen you know I don't show up
with the [ __ ] Fugazi [ __ ] in
everything I try to run to you people I
try to check them out see what's going
on with them
you know we does a little background
check the best that we could do we'll do
a little Yelp review well tell me what's
going on and this watch impressed the
hell out of me like I said people send
me stuff all the time and when I open
this watch so I looked at it at first I
got the gorilla wrist so the I needed a
bigger band and guess what Vince arrow
said that to me with no problem like two
days later so what I did was I put one
band on one wants that they sold me and
I put this metal watch on the silver on
white this arrow I love it I love it
and you guys northern whale watch it was
time for me to be a professional I got
twenty watches now this is the one I
wear from now only everything anything
else on me since I got this watched now
why it looks good people been
complimenting me
and it's just a nice watch it feels
great it's comfortable I like your watch
- thank you I don't know what it is I
don't know what I paid I don't know what
you paid for that don't care I'm just
telling you if you're looking for a
watch you know you're tired of choosing
between luxury styling and high-end
quality and an affordable price fact
then several watches wants to help with
timepieces that'll expertly blend style
timing and class with a price tag you'd
never expect the watch built this way
this well each collection is bold modern
and guaranteed to elevate your game okay
they feel great on your wrist and
honestly I received more compliments
like I said then any other watch I've
ever put on that's why I don't wear guys
if you're in the market for a great
watch I like to direct your attention to
the sweet piece on my wrist I absolutely
love this Vince arrow it's a dope brand
because they make watches that look and
feel luxurious while still giving you an
outfit that's distinct its unique you
look that is sure you get compliment by
people and that's why I'm wearing that
with the watch that's why I like I said
I picked up the white on white my
personal favorite though is the black
silver because you could wear it with
anything from really casual clothes to
street wear watches like this they
retail for 500 these were Sarah watches
they started a hundred and fifty dollars
they have over sixty-five hundred five
star reviews and another four hundred
five star reviews on Amazon
well they partnered with class factories
and only manufacturer in small batches
so that you get Ithaca ly produced
products subject to rigorous quality
control standards listen to me I'll tell
you this this is an end and I really
enjoy wearing this watch that's why I'm
bringing attention to Vince Aero so
whether you're attending an extravagant
III gala or whether you're going to a
dooku premiere Vince arrow has the
versatility that you need there's a
discount code guys when several is great
quali
it's something
credible watch with them in the presence
of your wrist these little rachis they
Rock don't just get a watch elevate your
game go to the cero watch go to check
out Vince arrow I get the watch dotnet
right now listen you don't get a nice
watch anyway this watch looks good feels
good it's beautiful the craftsmanship is
beautiful and guess what
they're affordable and that's what
you're looking to get right and now I'm
gonna give you 15% off the entire
purchase with promo code Church at
checkout it's time to step up your watch
game go check out lancero out I'd get to
watch dotnet listen to me women wants
this type of stuff you're a young man
you're trying to impress people you're
trying to get a job for the first
interview you got away one watch for the
second interview you gotta switch it up
so people see that you're a classy guy
now you don't have two to three thousand
dollars to throw away I don't watch and
I'm not asking to drop that's why I'm
directing you to get to watch that net
right now like I said then Sarah's gonna
give our church the family 15 percent
off the entire purchase with promo code
Church and check out please go to Vince
Aero watch right now right now I'm gonna
get the watch dotnet and take a look I'm
not kidding you it's a great deal on
these watches all right I want to thank
George Perez
I want to thank my manly syat I want to
thank Vince Aero watch I get to watch
dotnet right now and I want to thank you
people for being a great audience and
for letting us coming to your [ __ ]
homes once a week and torment you with
sickening and disgusting [ __ ] stories
that's what I love about you people got
heart you're the last real Americans you
like the rest of these whiny
[ __ ] that pop up with a story
every four days about something that
happened who gives a [ __ ] the people are
[ __ ] dead but now you gotta speak
your piece to get the [ __ ] out he said
people listen to this [ __ ] you people
are normal people who gives a [ __ ] stay
black uncle Joey loves you
I'll see you in Denver see at the ice
house I'll see at the Comedy Store
Sunday night I see and then the next
week and
see you [ __ ] savages and how a Bama
the Cana 10th planet in the house second
show Friday night 9:15 show gonna be his
face he's [ __ ] up how I like him baby
boys have a great week all right
stay black most importantly happy
Valentine's Day
have a great weekend I'll be in touch
via [ __ ] periscope go to Joey Diaz
dotnet for church t-shirts I love you
[Music]